welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information
about why you should never trust a
different version of yourself from a
different reality because who knows what
the real intentions might be
i would never trust me i'm just too
irresponsible i don't trust myself in
this reality
exactly that's what i'm saying brandon
my name is mt and i'm here today with
the off-screen producer
brandon what's going on brad hello mt
not much going on
i'm so excited to dive into the big
question with you again this week i
can't believe i'm back again i'm being
on screen too much they're gonna they're
gonna take away my time
there's there's no such thing as too
much branding
okay tell that tell that to my wife
[Laughter]
okay brandon hit me with that big
question all right all right let's do it
empty
okay so at the end of loki we're finally
introduced to he who remains right
and it's been confirmed 100 that it's
it's a version of kang the conqueror
right
i i just have so many questions about
this and it looks like he's going to be
the next
big bad in the mcu right he's going to
be in tons of properties he's going to
be this guy we fight at the end
so that guy's thinking about this week's
big question you know just how powerful
is kang like where does he fit in
amongst all these powerful bad guys
and people from the comics well i think
it's time to put some respect on kang's
name let's
do it yes please to get an understanding
of just how powerful kang is
we're going to look at some of his
various exploits in the comics because
there have been many variants of kang
that have appeared in the marvel comics
over the years such as you know my boy
rama tut
egyptian god um even though it's
cultural appropriation
that's classic that's classic classic
white people
[Laughter]
you got me we didn't get a chance to
conquer back then let's go back and fix
it you know what i mean
oh my god oh there we have a mortise of
course and then we have mr griffin
and your boy the strongest version of
kang kangaroo the conqueror
let's not forget him kangaroo the
conqueror oh yes he's
literally the strongest version he'll
kick everybody's ass i hope we get i
hope we see that in the mcu because if
we have a thanos copter
why not and of course iron lad just to
name a few and i put i put out a video
last week explaining some of these
variants
and how they could appear in upcoming
mcu titles so please check that out
after you watch this of course because
yeah we talking about how powerful kang
is
you don't want to miss out okay jeez but
it's also important to remember
that with any character that appears in
the comics over the decades powers and
abilities tend to vary
wildly depending on who's like writing
the story and what is needed for the
narrative art and also villains tend to
lose in the end
because you know it's comic books and
heroes have the ultimate flower
they're always making the villains lose
like come on guys let's let a villain i
know like what the heck's up with that
like especially like old comics from
like the 60s it's always like
oh yeah the villain just like i forgot
to turn my stove off at home
or my favorite is like freaking um
during the thanos copter thing when he's
like fighting hellcat or whatever he's
just like oops i
got the cube yeah yeah yeah i mean it
just drops the queue there's that like
classic uh is the old fantastic four
cartoon when magneto's like
ah that gun was made of wood
what that's why your power didn't work
okay but let's talk because one thing
all the kangs have in common
is that they are generally normal human
beings like they don't possess any
superpowers naturally except for their
genius level intellect of course because
that's the greatest superpower of all
knowledge the more you know the more you
know the more you hey
where are your kids seven o'clock where
are your kids i don't know
jesus i hope i don't have any kids right
that'd be terrible
someone was like hey where your kids
empty like you had kids i'm like i had
no idea i'd be like that's a variant
that's another reality
there's a mori show for like are you the
father like
there's several variants like who is the
father but um also since kings come from
the 31st century they do have
a longer lifespan in general thanks to
the advancements in medical technology
because as technology advances so does
medicine and
people live longer that's just how
things go and that's the basic advantage
that every kang comes equipped with
but they all use that genius level
intellect to add a few special features
because why wouldn't you
yeah i mean if i'm super smart i'm gonna
find ways to exploit that to take over
places
exactly i mean why wouldn't you i mean
why why not just like you know benefit
the world you know no no no
my nature as a white male is to take
over the world
oh my god two real two or two real i'm
gonna get burned in the comments
oh god hey man you're just speaking the
truth guy i appreciate it i appreciate
you dog
when it comes to nerdy [ __ ] like
engineering and physics especially in
the realm of time travel
kang's big brain makes him a huge threat
like he often uses some sort of fancy
chair to travel through time
or sometimes even a freaking sphinx like
a whole sphinx thing
from egypt he uses that to travel
through time sometimes but in the mcu
they will probably relate his time
traveling abilities to the quantum realm
because
that's where all that [ __ ] goes down i
remember really i remember when that
we first saw like the void in in loki mt
you were like so excited to see the
sphinx
because like does it yes like romantic
like travels through
the sphinx is like a time machine right
exactly and like when i saw that i was
like yo
that's probably an old time machine
that's correct that one of the kangs
used
like during the world war tang and like
you know that or maybe that's the time
machine that
he remains used to use but yeah because
tank and time travel he has access to
technology across
all of time this means that he can pull
up whatever super weapon he may need to
defeat whoever stands in his way because
like
he has everything like the whole time
stream that he can just pluck technology
from so he's like hmm
you know what would work a death ray
from the year six thousand i need that
for this
for this particular thing so he just
grabs it it's really great i would love
that for example rahmatut the king who
took over ancient egypt had something
called an
ultra diode gun this weapon could drain
the the hero
of their superpowers and take away a
target's
free will and if you're paying attention
to last week's big question
you already know that there's no free
will anyway so you know who cares
there's no free will
oh no no oh no
that was such a fun big question with me
and jess if you haven't checked it out
please check it out
we get it we dive into mcu free will
it's really interesting it doesn't exist
and as we saw with he who remains kang
knows what happens
across the timeline so he can use this
information to a tactical
advantage he can learn the history and
the future of any foe he is going to
face
and then use that information against
them because again
why wouldn't you if you know what's
going to happen in the future
then you can get some intel yeah if you
were like
i could like go to my when my boss was
like a kid and getting picked on in
school
and be like and find out what his
weakness was and then come back and be
like
exactly i know i know that you peed your
pants in fourth grade
i know you're allergic to peanut butter
better give me a raise [ __ ] give me
that race do you think there's ever been
like a villain
like a major villain in any comic who
had like a very simple allergy
and he was like gee you know like it's
just like uh
the joker being like i hope no one finds
out that i'm allergic to latex
not surgical gloves like the red skull
has got irritable bowel syndrome they're
just like
oh not spicy foods and like it just
kills anybody who finds that
right yo you know too much
the waiter at pf changs just gets killed
immediately you go to a taco balance
like none of you guys are gonna make it
i'm so sorry this taco is too spicy
you are failing me hilarious and red
skull had like a lactose intolerance but
like he just
he just didn't want to admit it he just
kept on eating milk
this ice cream is delicious i cannot
stop
i need to powder my nose you don't have
a nose
just tell me what the bathroom is i
wonder if if he can even taste because
he has no nose oh i mean
that's next week's big question don't
get ahead of yourself
right get the red skull taste okay so
loki and sylvie weren't able to land a
blow on him until the very end because
he knew every move
that they were going to make right right
he was always dodging out of the way
because he's like
man i already saw this if you're
fighting in like an omniscient
bad guy like they're gonna have a one-up
on you but that's also hard too cause
like you know we've all played dance
dance revolution and it's like even
though you know the song 50 times
it's still hard to get the moves right
every time it's true like
tangles have like a really big brain if
you can memorize like
everything that that photographic memory
doc yo
he's true he sounded tough he sounded
tough you're convincing me empty
well i'm glad um in most cases choose to
wear a battle suit that gives them
increased strength and endurance and the
king that prances around
as iron lad even has his own iron
man-esque suit
that gives him the additional ability to
fly and shoot energy blasts
from his hands so that's that suit the
traditional suit that
we see kang wearing like the green and
purple with like the blue face that's
like a power suit
exactly like kang doesn't actually have
a blue face like the blue face comes
from his suit that he puts on
it doesn't look like a very powerful
suit it looks like a jumpsuit but i
guess it's strong
it's future technology right
you know it was back in the day so like
they had like interesting ideas of what
futuristic suits would look like in the
in the 31st century they're gonna wear
very baggy clothes very baggy uh
green and with purple with some blue
face like that's going to be the style
that's what all the kids are going to
wear
yeah honestly this seems like some i
feel like this is kanye's doing hey
bro you stop it all right you stopped it
all right
this is kind of his influence on the
world he had those like touchy suits
right
he wore those on his spinel when he was
bouncing 110
wear kang's entire outfit what's the
name of your clothing line we don't know
do you think kanye's a king
[Laughter]
but okay let's take a look at some of
the foes kang has faced in the comic
books to get an idea of just how
powerful
the man is and let's start off with kang
versus the avengers because kang
has faced the avengers on multiple
occasions in the marvel comics and
usually the avengers of course
come out on top of the end because
comics but on one occasion
kang was able to get them to surrender
the entire planet
the entire planet brand dude did they
have the authority to do that did they
take a vote
they surrendered the planet yeah i think
they called every country like hey
you good with us surrendering the entire
planet it's like oh yeah it's totally
fine go for it
okay i just checked all right i'm sure
they had their reasons i'm sure they had
because during the kang dynasty or kang
wars comics run in 2001
kang had his armies attacked the planet
in multiple occasions
as part of his devious plan and he even
wiped out the entire population
of washington dc which is kind of crazy
that's a lot of people
i mean some of them can go some of the
politicians
i'll say it no seriously you all suck am
i right
i don't want to get arrested
no but and he was so successful in his
scheme that the avengers wound up
signing
the declaration of surrender which is
the exact opposite
of what benjamin franklin the boys yeah
back in the day and in the end
kang is betrayed by his son marcus
because you can never trust demarcus i
mean
yuck yeah i'm watching you marcus i'm
watching him i'm watching you marcus
so while he may be a great tactician he
got done in by one of his own family so
that's that's pretty damning
it's cold that's cool brother i mean
like come on that's a very disappointing
episode of mori povich right you are the
father
and your son just just betrayed you yo
but i
i think in that run he actually betrays
his father because he falls in love with
captain marvel
yeah so you know carol danvers hey man
if it's if it's brie larson i would
portray my phone i mean i love brilliant
yeah
sorry dad i'm sorry dad
but let's get into kang vs captain
america because during those very same
king wars king actually goes one-on-one
with
the old man himself the senior citizen
captain america
steve rogers i love whatever people
fight captain america i'm like well i
can't believe you would fight an old man
right he served our country in world war
ii
hi there young people a nice day today
so you like kicking butts do ya well
we'll show you old man
thanks to his battle suit he's able to
keep up with captain america in combat
but
cap ultimately takes him down in the end
of course though nothing gets capped
madder than a tyrant
bringing genocide to an entire planet oh
yeah i bet cap was like pissed off
right cap's got that fire inside yeah he
can't replicate american pride
justice and liberty baby
and of course we got a showdown that a
lot of people on the internet have come
across
uh now that kang is popular kang vs
thanos because we all know how powerful
the man thanos is like this man fought
all the avengers
he's the titan he's by himself he's a
titan he's the mad titan
he's crazy the bad titan did manage to
beat the avengers and wipe out
half of all life in the universe though
he who remains showed us that kang
merely allowed him to do that but what
would happen if they went toe-to-toe
what would happen
because in a recent comic run called
avengers mech strike
a young thanos without the infinity
gauntlet teams up with the avengers to
take on kang
and well uh it doesn't go great for the
giant uh purple people defeater because
kang
unleashed the power of time onto thanos
and literally like pushes him through
his entire lifespan
in like one second like someone called m
night shyamalan because
your boy looking old interesting
so it's like a younger he beat a younger
thanos who doesn't have the infinity
gauntlet but it's still pretty strong
you know thanos without the infinity
gauntlet is still very very strong yeah
he's just like he does not need the
offended goblet to beat your ass
so it seems like like thanos is like
your brute force
villain he's smart but he's moving brute
force
that's how he gets things done but i'm
seeing a pattern here that kang is very
smart he's very tactical mm-hmm uh and
he uses like his knowledge of time to
his advantage okay okay
moving god we have kang vs uh the planet
eater galactus
oh like good god what uh what a match-up
because while kang
hasn't exactly fought galactus directly
in the comics there was a run in the
marvel exiles where king acquired the
power
of a dead galactus from another reality
and then altered his desire
for eating planets into a hunger for
devouring entire realities because
galactus wasn't hungry enough you know
it's why not
eat realities and thus we got the time
eater because if you can't beat them
while they're alive
you know just wait till they're dead and
then use their body as a weapon you know
pretty smart move gang that is smart i
mean because like no one can really beat
galactus i mean galactus is pretty tough
if you're going to fight him head on but
just wait till he dies
miss keisha miss keisha oh
just like the collector said the groot
he's like hey can i have your body at
the time of your death
because like you're using it now but
like yeah i'll just take a magnificent
magnificent
um now let's talk kang versus ultron
because this one is a little unfair to
our boy king what's up
mt no what did you say what's the
language
um in a 1984 issue during the secret
wars run
dr doom is a little pissed off at kang
and orders ultron to kill him and he
does so
pretty swiftly like you would think that
kang would have seen this coming but
this was the secret wars so everything
was a little bit screwed maybe this was
like the dumbest kang
out there farewell the dumbest version
of gang
may you rest in peace still pretty smart
dumb ding dang dig day
the dumb gang um okay though to be fair
doctor doom has also wondered if he
himself
is a kang and doesn't really know it so
that's some weird like
mind-bending stuff like am i okay are
you okay
like who is a gang maybe we're all okay
put me on maury povich
[Music]
bishop you are a king exactly we need a
kang test
you know we got with a birth test
23andme for kangs
but since kang is the master of time
travel he can't be sure that he isn't
king from a different time
so maybe kang ordered ultron to kill
himself
during the secret wars checkmate oh okay
so kang's really up on it
yeah because doctor doom the idea that
like you're a kang
who like came back in time but maybe
forgot
or like you've tricked yourself into not
knowing you're a king
because like dr dooms related to kang
right yeah so
dr doom is potentially a an ancestor to
uh
okay you're not my dad who knows like
maybe it could be kang being an ancestor
to himself but uh i personally like to
think that um
uh doctor doom and nathaniel richards
kissed at one point
and uh they made the babies just kidding
that's okay there's a reality where that
happens
reality is empty yes there's a reality
where me and doctor do kiss
and it's very passionate you know he's
got that tight metal body
i hope i hope my gay mt variant is
living the best life i hope he's leading
the the pride parade
in 2022 i hope so honestly i hope so
but let's compare kang to other mcu
villains now because
okay you know we got kang coming up and
he's already gone toe to toe with
you know two mtu villains already with
loki and sylvie
yo i i need we need to see jonathan
major's contract because what does that
look like dude i hope it what is it is
it
pay for each gang right like how many
like how many
appearances do they have them signed up
for because we're getting so many kegs
coming up so like hopefully
it's about a hundred hopefully get a
hundred uh
i'm all about it but yes let's compare
some uh keg to other fcu villains
because how would kang compare to other
powerful villains we've seen the mcu
already because we can take a look at
the celestial ego for what is it because
ego was an immensely powerful being
with a plan to reshape the universe how
he saw fit he just decided hey
uh the universe doesn't have enough me
in it so let's just make it all me
why not however he has spent a fair
amount of his recent existence
trying to make a celestial offspring to
power his spores so while kang may not
be able to beat a celestial hand to hand
he may be able to outsmart them or at
least travel to a point
when they are the most vulnerable and
then defeat them with some futuristic
weapon
designed for killing celestials yeah
like when ego was just pulling himself
together or into a brain right
ken could just show up and like squash
him or something like that yeah like
yeah you know what just gonna end this
process you've been terminated
plus like as you pointed out like kang
has he has like the
the knowledge of time and can move back
and forth so
you know someone like ego who's been
alive for a long time
uh and has time to think about it and is
patient and can wait
he still is kind of living in the moment
right because he doesn't know what the
future holds he has his plan
and he's eager to get it done he's
waited millennia to get it done
so he's in a rush but like kang is just
like i can wait until the perfect moment
and if i miss the moment i can go back
to it exactly
i'm like you know ego got defeated by
the guardians of the galaxy but a bunch
of a-holes right
so you know what a bunch of a-holes he's
not infallible
yes he's a celestial but he was like
kind of a
spare celestial like off doing his own
thing i'm also wondering
with kang like does kang are is already
more powerful than celestials like i
have this feeling that kang
is already in just by his nature by
being outside of reality by being
outside of the multiverse is already
stronger than
everybody within the universe so that
includes celestials and like as a
guardian gods as we see
so like who knows i think that maybe
kane could
maybe go hand to head with him and maybe
just like take his powers away yeah i
guess i guess we'll have to see
they haven't really told us because
that's the one thing that celestials
have is they exist
beyond universe endings right like they
yeah i think that's exactly what
happened they created by the first ever
like eternity
right and he created the the celestials
and the aspirants
and then they went on their war so like
yeah i think they do survive
this is i'm not sure getting that
sinking feeling in my stomach can we go
back to talking about
just like catastrophe yes they're in the
world okay so what about
what about like a god like how how does
king
like match up to a god i would say same
goes for a god like hella because we've
already seen
kang outmaneuver a host of variants in
one particular god of mischief in season
one of love oh yeah well i guess he
outsmarted every loki ever right
everywhere like look he outsmarted like
hella was like a pretty strong
god goddess oh yeah uh very very but she
was also able to be contained right like
odin kept her locked away uh so in
theory like
kang could find a way to lock her away
or like go to a point in time when they
developed a god gun that could shoot
guns
and just yank that out and be like boom
gotcha caught you slipping
gotcha gotcha slipping hella and kate
doesn't always need to defeat
his foes because sometimes his plans are
even more strategic because at one point
in the comics
he even attempts to capture and wed the
celestial madonna in order to copulate
and produce some powerful offspring to
rule the universe like you know like ego
styles
women women love it when you just like
capture them and marry them
oh so it's it's the best thing you know
in the world it's like
not having the will to make your own
decisions
women dig it they love it that's not
true don't listen like i don't want to
give in cells any ideas like hey you're
right
not the most romantic pitch you would
try on a woman and it doesn't
work out for kang in the end as the
avengers foil his plan
to help with rama tut but again
sometimes you're your own worst enemy
what is up with like
kang's turning against kangs constantly
it is a very
common thing in the in the comics
especially with immortus who like is
constantly trying to um
you know foil his other kangs well they
kind of set it up in loki because
uh he who remains is like you know we
just we're always fighting each other
every kang wants to be the leader so
it's like you can't trust any kings
i think that that's why he finds you
know these loki's working together so
intriguing
right because he can't work together
with any of his kangs oh what about
we got the eternals coming up right
right is kang stronger than an eternal i
mean it's
i'm maybe he is it sounds like he's
smarter i mean he definitely would know
a lot more than the eternal which is
kind of weird considering that the
eternals have been around for so long
right
so like to have someone that is like has
a one-up on you
because you're going through time the
long way around it's very interesting
yeah they're going the slow way kang's
just jumping around
he's speed reading time yes and so like
there's a big chance that we will see
um a ramatat kang in the eternals film
because like that film goes throughout
the
centuries throughout humanity's history
so it's possible that ramata will face
off against the eternals in ancient
egypt but we will have to wait and see
but to wrap everything up here as we
continue to head into
the next phase of the mcu kang is very
much shaping up to be
like a powerful adversary in the mcu
that we will be seeing
very soon and there won't just be one
big bad this time like there was with
phantoms and
our heroes are probably going to be
facing multiple kangs from different
realities and each of them
hell-bent on conquering it all so i
can't wait for it oh man this is a
really interesting thing it sounds super
exciting i
i really like it this is a great like
level up on storytelling you know yes
we had one big bad and now we've got
like so many of the same big bads
yes yeah like it makes me so happy that
like
the multiverse is now like a popular
thing that everyone can grasp yeah like
everyone understands the concept because
of loki
loki was literally multiverse 101 like
variance 101 like
what a very smart like kevin feige made
this show specifically
to prepare everyone very small what's
coming next in the phase of
kanye feige he taught us all about it
gandhi feige he's a variant he knows
he knows a sacred timeline but a great
way for you and any of your variants to
support new rockstars is by checking out
our merch
at new rockstarsmerch.com we got a
limited supply of loki merch left
including a shirt featuring mobius
finally getting that jet ski ride he so
desperately deserved in season one
of loki that we never got shame on you
everyone
see him on the jet ski give him a check
we need the jet ski season two better
start with the jet ski like i don't want
anything else
just give me like 50 minutes of mobius
on a jet ski for episode one i'm just
saying that
um but we also have some exclusive black
widow-inspired merch like this shirt
with all those
black widows nice little nesting dolls
i love it it's so cute i love it very so
cute so deadly it's a great way to
support the channel
and all the awesome content we pump out
on the secret timeline so please head on
over
and check out all of our merch options
over at newrocksourcemerch.com and
before we dive into our bite size
questions next
some words from the folks that help
bring big question and all of our
amazing programs
to you people like imperfect foods it's
a busy time of year so it's okay that
you're not perfect and guess what
neither is food and that's where
imperfect food comes in imperfect foods
is a grocery delivery service that has
created an
entire line of sustainable groceries
like pantry staples that taste delicious
embrace imperfection and get your
groceries delivered weekly with
imperfect foods
all you have to do is sign up
personalize your weekly order and then
shop online each week and get
sustainable groceries that help you
invest in a better food system all
delivered to your front door and in 2019
35 of the food supply went unsold or
uneaten in the u.s
and perfect foods is working to turn
this around by sourcing foods
that would otherwise fall through the
cracks of our food system to reduce
waste
imperfect foods is the first grocery
delivery company that makes it easy
to return your packaging to them after
every order and right now
imperfect foods is offering our audience
20 off your first four orders when you
go to imperfectfoods.com
and use promo code big question again
that's 20
off your first four orders that's up to
an 80 value
at imperfectfoods.com using promo code
big question and we also want to thank
upstart for sponsoring this video
because so many americans experience
financial hardship in the last year and
upstart
can help you regain your footing and get
things back on track because upstart is
a fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan
all online so whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt
or funding personal expenses over half a
million people have used upstart to get
one
fixed monthly payment upstart knows that
you are more than just your credit score
and it's expanding access
to affordable credit because unlike
other lenders upstart considers your
income and current employment
to find you a smarter rate with a five
minute online rate check
you can see your rate up front for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars and you can receive funds
as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan so find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today
when you go to upstart.com bigquestion
that is upstart.com
bigquestion and don't forget to use our
url to let us know that we
sent you and load amounts will be
determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided on your loan application
go to upstart.com bigquestion today
and uh get your loan [ __ ] figured out
[Laughter]
forget your [ __ ] money okay all right
it is time for our bite-sized questions
of the neighboring are you ready oh i'm
ready empty i got some good answers for
you
okay i got a question for you brandon
the question of the first question of
the day is
what is the strangest real world cameo
in comics oh buddy
this is a good question i mean over the
years have been plenty of strange
real world cameos and comic books from
like actors and athletes to musicians
and historical figures
i went through a ton there's like so
many look these up because they're
hilarious and weird
but these are some of my favorites that
i found okay uh in the 1970s
superman boxed muhammad ali which
seems completely unfair it seems
completely like right
i mean like i'm not from the 70s but
like that's an iconic comment right
right
like it's like around the covers like
superman versus muhammad ali
yeah spoiler alert muhammad ali wins i
don't know how
oh i mean it's a kryptonite fist man
yeah yeah
i think i think some bookies paid
superman to take a dime or something
like that
oops you're gonna go down in the fourth
round okay
otherwise i'm gonna break lois's legs
this is this is another good one eminem
the rapper
uh team teamed up with the punisher uh
oh and they weren't just out there
spitting fire lyrics i mean the cover
has m like a gun like a uzi it's crazy
[Laughter]
yeah he like loves comics he's made a
lot of references to it but it's so
funny
uh this one i thought was really funny
uh in ultimates number four from 2002
you know mark millar's like ultimates
run great stuff love it really inspired
the mcu a lot
um but it's revealed that uh uh hulk's
you know main lady betty ross she's like
on a date with uh freddy prince jr
and i like pisses off the hulk and uh
the panel is like the hulk screaming
like
freddy burst jr and like they asked
freddie prince jr about it like 2014 and
he had like a funny
he said like you know bring it on hulk
or whatever but it's just funny like
what a weird thing also a weird fact
about freddie prince jr he was a writer
for the wwe
like in really late 2000 like in the
2010s or something like that yeah
he likes wrestling he was a writer like
very weird brady prince jr it's just
funny like the whole being like
[Laughter]
wait was this like after like the
scooby-doo movie was this like around
that time yeah i think it's just 2002
he was really popular at the time
betty ross they just went on a date i
mean we don't know what happened
okay uh the fantastic four met the
beatles
i mean that's very fun right i mean hey
if you're gonna be a time traveling
family why not
yeah yeah beetles um there's of course
presidents have shown up in the comics
a lot uh obama was in a spider-man comic
uh george bush i think uh george bush
jr george w bush he showed up in like a
comic he had to like lick magneto's boot
or something like that like magneto
i don't think the writers were happy
with george w at the time you know
sure he's like painting now but the
man's a war criminal look it up look it
up
i mean superman superman has met both
like bill and hillary clinton uh and he
also met jfk
though he wasn't faster than that's
bridging bullet you know what i mean
yeah
uh i don't think i'm not completely sure
but i think he met jfk like
after he was assassinated it's weird um
it's kind of weird
uh and this is the weirdest one like
abraham lincoln teamed up with spider
man and captain america in like a comic
book which is very strange the cover is
great
uh very wow um oh oh god
i need to read that one because that
sounds like a great very strange i think
this was
like the height of like abraham lincoln
vampire hunter fun times
this kind of thing we were really having
fun with abraham lincoln a few years ago
uh superman saved orson welles once that
was very fun
uh rodney dangerfield took over for tony
stark in the iron man suit but it was
just to like tell some jokes
uh like a thing he didn't go around
fighting okay uh
kiss the knights in satan's service uh
the band kiss
they've appeared in both howard the duck
and archie comics so they've crossed
that makes
that makes sense they've crossed like
different uh
comic boundaries uh david letterman
interviewed the avengers
uh once and this this is the weirdest
one this one is very strange
charles barkley played basketball
against godzilla
[Music]
okay i thought you're gonna say superman
or something
and you might be thinking oh so godzilla
was small right no no no no
charles barkley got like some weird
magic silver dollar from a fan and it
made him huge
oh okay so they play basketball like
yeah they then they play best like giant
sized basketball
which i don't understand how godzilla
knew the rules about it's not fair to
godzilla
you know what i mean seriously like i
like to think there was like an
hour where godzilla was explaining the
rules sebastian charles barkley's
barely understood basketball like you
know i'll bet a basketball
game and they'll be they'll blow the
whistle i'll be like that's a foul like
what what
i don't know what happened um
and i think i think godzilla gets some
like nikes in the end or something like
giant shirts
oh word very strong oh damn i would love
to see what what size that godzilla
wears
so yeah those are like the weirdest the
weirdest
my favorite like kind of real world
cameos and comic books but go look them
up there's a ton of them
okay i got another question for you okay
here's another one what other versions
of rick and morty have we seen that
don't look like the normal rick and
morty for example
hammer morty and all that stuff and this
is from iaj
smith24 on discord so thank you yes
yes thank you aj smith so many always
asking good questions
and you know you kind of laid it out but
we'll assume like a normal rick and
morty is like the humanoid versions
which we mostly see like humanoid
versions of them
um but you know since rick and morty has
established like there's infinite
you know universes with like infinite
possibilities any type of wicked mortar
you could imagine exists
uh but we we have seen a few but if you
dream it it's possible you know what i
mean yes kids remember that
if you dream it you can achieve it you
can achieve it you
you could do so you you do you could you
you want you want him to do you so much
you could do anything
uh but here's some of our favorite like
non-humanoid
weird rick and morties we've seen over
the years of course ia.j smith pointed
out uh
hammerhead morty which we saw in close
close rick counters of the rick kind
uh and that would too we also saw alien
rick and morty you know just kind of
like very green looking alien guys
you might remember from rick potion
number nine there's like the cronenberg
universe so we had cronenberg
uh rick and morty um and then tales of
the citadel we also saw
lizard rick and morty you see wizard uh
lizard morty's one of the main
guys that they kind of like stand by me
storyline but there is like a lizard
rick like
crawling in the background somewhere
that you can find
and then tales of the citadel we also
saw like a fish version of rick and
morty you're like a
merman kind of version aqua aqua rick
and morty
uh and then there's fishy rick fish
and then the episode edge of to morty
rick die
rick pete great name great movie great
name
i love that movie there's a few weird
iterations we see in that one when he's
kind of jumping
uh into his different like clones though
most of them were fascist
you know it's a problem it happens a lot
the multiverse apparently yeah
you know it happens uh of course you
like rock
wasp rick and morty and that horrifying
scene where they eat the teacher
alive which is like he's screaming for
his babies and they start eating his
babies
it's just terrible oh we see like 10 g
fun
we see like teddy bear rick who's like
straight up fascists already and then of
course we see shrimp
rick and morty uh again most important
versions
the most important and most delicious
versions um
so and then if you go into like the rick
and morty comics there's like even more
there's like a cat
mortar you see at some point and like
all sorts and then there's like the
pocket morty's mobile game
which has even like way weirder versions
of morty you don't see different
versions of rick but you see like all
the weird
morty's and you can assume that there's
a rig to match like clock face
morty there's probably i don't know how
canon
like the game is but yeah there's like a
ton there so we've seen some really cool
ones some weird ones but we'll probably
see a few more before the
season's over huh yeah i would imagine
so but like also you mentioned the rick
and morty comics
anybody who loves rick and morty and
does not read the rick and morty
comments you are missing out i like them
i'm basically
more seasons of rick and morty like they
are fantastically written comics
they're hilarious it's literally like
you're watching a storyboard of a rick
and morty episode but it's like
fully drawn out and like it's spot-on
one-to-one
like it's fantastic when you're reading
it do you do the voices in your head
yes like it's it's hard not to because
it's so well written
it's such a good [ __ ] so anybody out
there please go read the rich promoter
yeah
they're very very funny but yes now it
is time for one of my favorite segments
of the show
it's the box of scraps the box of
scramps the box of scraps
the boss is
so today's box of scraps question is if
you had to go back in time and conquer
any time period any time period where
would you go
and how would you conquer brandon um
that's a great question mt well i think
you know to make up
for my uh you know my my horrible
white ancestry i would go back uh
you know to early uh native american
times
uh the indigenous people of north
america and i would help them
fend off all these colonies colonialists
coming in
and stuff uh and you know it'd be crazy
because i you know
they were living hunted gatherers like
having a nice time you know i would just
bring a little bit
of my modern knowledge it now i'm not
very smart uh but i think i could give
them a few heads up like hey don't trade
the blankets
uh let's get some mold going let's get
some penicillin out of that
uh and fight off some of these diseases
are coming uh because you know i don't
know if you know this empty but like
there's like
evidence that uh just before the kind of
colonialist came in the kind of 1600s
that did the settling and really
laid the groundwork that um there was a
big period of die off
around the indigenous people from other
kind of diseases that were going around
and that's why north america and the
americas hadn't been colonized before
because like there's evidence that like
the vikings were showing up
you know way before like the europeans
came and
uh the spanish came and stuff and they
would show up and the native americans
would like fight them off and be like
you can trade with us but you're not
staying you know what i mean
yeah but by the time like you know the
pilgrims start showing up there had been
this like massive die off so they didn't
have the numbers to fight off people
anymore
and so you know the europeans are
showing up they find these big
empty areas that hadn't cleared out
because the people who lived there were
gone now
but they're like oh this is a great
place to set up shop and then the native
americans were like
well we've we've had some tough times we
need to do some trading and like
build up our numbers and then they got
screwed okay yeah i'd be there to be
like hey guys we gotta keep
these people out of here i'm on your
side because that was the other thing
like
these caught you know the pilgrims and
the colonists would show up and like
people would run away and join the
native americans because they were
living
great lives kicking it back hunter
gathering the women had a lot of
autonomy and power in there and they
hated being with the colonials and the
clones would actually go
grab these people and drag them back
into like the areas
because they were like we need your help
building a society you're like no i want
to go look at these people they're
having a great time
they know how to live berries
[Laughter]
have you ever heard of like jonestown
where it was like this big mystery where
this town like this
all these colonists disappeared and they
don't know what happened a lot of people
think that like they probably just ran
off and they're like
europe you know england we don't like
the dutch we're out of here
we're joined in the native americans so
that's where that's where i would go
totally rewrite history uh and you know
no more shopping malls we're living with
the land forever tp's in buffalo
it's gonna be great it's gonna be great
hey man that's
that's a really good one i'm gonna write
some wrong see i'm going to write some
wrongs
hey i i appreciate it you know all of us
brown folks would appreciate if you go
went back in time and gave christopher
columbus a wedgie oh that would be uh
really great
screw that guy screw that guy honestly
straight up what am i
a terrible person terrible monstrous man
yeah i would conquer ancient rome yeah
if i went back in time i would conquer
ancient rome
just so hey i could stop the whole
gladiator thing
because looking back that's terrible
like they made people fight to the death
yeah it's just really terrible
but like each of rome that's like a
really good time to
to come in and take over a whole empire
yeah and that was a huge empire
that was assembled so if i just came in
with my iphone and be like hey
check out my future technology and like
my knowledge of like i don't know
vaccines and sicknesses even though i
wouldn't know i mean there's no internet
to connect to empty
also when that battery dies it's gonna
be time it's like
it's like i need to come back i need to
google something because i want to go to
2021 google something that comes up i
think if you know
it's not like you're instantly
transported if you know you're gonna go
back in time you study up a little bit
maybe you take a couple years you'll
learn a little roman history
learn about the problems like no i just
need to play assassin's creed you know
beat nzo know which know which rooftops
you got to jump on
uh you'll be fine i'm bringing my copy
of assassin's creed to
the roman times and i'm going to play it
right in front of their faces
oh my god he's a wizard a solar
generator maybe a solar generator too
exactly what are those that would
definitely help me with my wi-fi
problems
uh for sure so i would choose ancient
rome i like it um
but that is it for this episode of big
question i want to thank
off-screen producer brandon for joining
me this episode as like he is fantastic
show him some love in the comics and
follow him at grindenberric on twitter
if you want to
see what he's up to on the the interwebs
not too much
follow him anyway because he's amazing
and we all love brandon we love you
brandon i love you emt
this is so much fun you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube and make sure to hit that
notification bell so you get
notifications whenever we upload dope
[ __ ] which is
pretty much every day so thank you guys
so much for watching and we'll see you
guys next time
[Music]
bye
you